is Peter Schrager co-host NFL Network's
good morning football which airs Monday
through Friday at 7:00 a.m. Eastern NFL
Network providing live coverage of the
draft from Dallas Fox will simulcast NFL
network's coverage rounds one two and
three as we make way for Peter Schrager
thanks for coming up the block and
joining us I love being here I wanted to
congratulate you guys an Emmy nomination
Sports Emmy best Daily Show that's
awesome stuff man yeah you guys got
nominated before last year the year
before in football first year we got
nominate we did not get nominated this
year I have no answer for that I guess
we got works I love the show yeah panel
didn't didn't feel the same I was told
that Kay Adams and some of the other
people there were blaming you it might
be my fault
yeah we're spending too much time
wanting to be a sideline reporter and
you pretty much mailed it in Monday
through Friday that's that's exactly not
I'm paraphrasing what they told me oh
that's exactly right
it is funny though you start looking in
the mirror so what could I have done
better there's been 360 shows I don't
think it's really much you could have
done better okay the damage have a
question here man
McLovin your question for for Peters
once so Peter we're grinding over here
about what to wear you know did we go
tux do we go you know do I call up a
designer I mean I said we're gonna
interview us on the red carpet and say
what are you wearing or do we just go
suit I go suit I go suit no tie I think
that's that's a look that's like I'm in
but I'm not fully in and you know I've
seen the jeans at the sports Emmys I
would go against it guy you don't you
don't want to be the guy that some
executive is there whispering this guy
wear jeans to the sports Emmys you know
I would go suit no time oh they're gonna
be whispering those guys got nominates
the whisper you're going to get ya
pulling at what point the proceedings is
our category best daily show cuz we
would like to go to a bar beforehand
what time do we had to enter the
building to be there in case were picked
great question the event is about 13
hours long so you're probably in like
the 11th to 12th hour so you will sit
through all of those best short news
features but long news feature there's a
lot of awards and you guys will be
towards the end this is what I'm
thinking because I think best studio
host is maybe the second one
warden so you get in early I get
disappointed early yeah when I don't win
and then I can text you guys to let you
know when our categories up for Best
daily sports show and then if you guys
in I don't know if you can stay do want
us to know if they can sneak in beer I
don't know it's a fancy event do you
want to be the guy who sneaking in beer
to a fancy event if that's the case yes
but okay the votes are already in right
I'm gonna guess right yeah okay so we
can't jeopardize this real sports wins
everything everything and we're all
terrible journalists cuz we're not in
Baghdad doing a story about some kid
with you know an issue who's playing
golf and also playing soccer
Jeremy shap just won another one Aaron
Cohen is one other writing award but
Costas isn't up this year is he not he
wins every year - he does it's so
disappea TI which you know they showed a
sample of it they did a sample of their
show and I was like Sonny Liston or
Muhammad Ali and they're arguing and I
looked at Kyle brand my co-host with a
new show it's when you wake up in the
middle of night yes and it's called
pardon the urination and so I I had this
thought last night as I'm going back to
bed it was from 1 to 1:15 and I said
whose future would you rather have this
actually came to love this you I had
Mike Trout okay I had who's my guy
friends are per show our show hey itani
Mike Trout proven thing I know what I'm
getting MVP awards I'm taking my trout
center field big position okay trout but
Otani is the unicorn too short too short
a career week I mean come on
we usually jump we have our opinions
established by them all right where do
you stand on its lying season as I tell
this audience that nobody wants to tell
you the truth what do you feel like you
know is actual gospel right now Baker
Mayfield will be taken in those top five
picks like everyone is saying like I've
spoken to multiple teams and the feeling
is that Mayfield will go that high I
then I've gone through the history books
I went through it and
I really went back to like the 1970s
there has never been a quarterback under
six foot one drafted in the top five of
the I get this guy's gonna break the
mold is he that good is that the issue
does anyone want to raise our hand and
say hey he got arrested less than two
years ago like it but teams are falling
in love with this guy when they meet him
in person and I am NOT waving the Baker
Mayfield flag because I think there's a
reason would you take him into town [ __ ]
I I would rather have alland Arnold and
Rosen I think because of just the
history of guys who are built bigger and
have that sign no you won't you could
roll your eyes and say well look at
Russell Wilson third-round pick look at
Drew Brees second-round pick I could
give you Colt McCoy and Johnny Manziel
and countless others it doesn't it's so
rich for a guy who there's not a long
history of quarterbacks taking that high
most likely to be the bust out of the
top five or these five quarterbacks I
don't know about bust I think Josh Rosen
could slip though I the stuff that
you're here and all these other guys is
football stuff the stuff that you hear
on Josh Rosen is does he love the game
is he going to be the first quarterback
in the building is he going to be the
last one to leave does he want it's
about and a lot of that stuff I just
roll my eyes at because everyone says
Josh Rosen comes from a very privileged
background if you guys don't know his
father is one of the top spinal surgeons
in the world all right his his mother's
from the Wharton family which is the
University of Pennsylvania School of
Business he doesn't have to play
football so people hold that against him
and they're like look he's into other
things he talks about Elon Musk more
than he does about football I don't know
if that's my guys I think then again if
he doesn't need football and he chooses
to play football and he's getting his
butt kicked at UCLA and he gets up every
single is that the guy you kind of want
that this isn't everything it's not all
his eggs are in this basket he's not
this desperate I kind of like his
attitude I kind of like his personality
and to a man everyone I'll tell you when
you look at just pure throwing motion
and the consistency it is Josh Rosen
overall of yeah that's true I was
talking to former NFL scout who said
last night as you get closer more and
more people are gonna fall in love with
Rosen because of that pure he is the
best passer in you know Josh Allen's got
the best arm that doesn't mean anything
if you can't use it correctly and that
Josh Rosen is the best pure passer and
the football IQ those are things you do
you should fall in love with it's almost
like there
that are creating obstacles there that
maybe they shouldn't and then there was
the report where they were you know
Stephen H Smith and I think Keyshawn
Johnson said he would like to go to New
York because of the Jewish community and
I said did they do any research that
he's actually an atheist more than he is
practicing Jew and I've followed up on
that Shaker Heights is one of the
biggest Jewish communities in the
country it's in Cleveland I love Josh
Rosie this is not and he never said that
so I would hate to have that out there
that like Josh Rosen made that claim
that's a very irresponsible thing to put
out there I will say this I spoke to an
offensive coordinator this week who said
it is like going to baskin-robbins there
are 31 flavors and it's very rare that
you're gonna fall in love with more than
one of these guys so if you're the Jets
at 3 & 2 quarterbacks go are you
settling on taking a quarterback if it's
a third pick and it's the third guy on
your board or are you convincing
yourself that no no we love this guy
because GM's don't get to top five picks
at quarterback basically it's like this
is your shot and you have to hit a home
run but but it's Jets Ian that they they
trade up but they they don't know who
they're getting that's it so they're
gonna go hey we'll take Baker Mayfield
it has to be Josh Rosen that has to be
they have to say we are so comfortable
with the four of them that no matter who
falls to us we're gonna be good riding
with because they are gonna take a
quarterback they say Quan Barker gets be
sitting there and he could be the next
Barry Sanders they're gonna take a
quarterback he's peter Schrager NFL
Network's good morning football co-host
and the reason why they didn't get
nominated for Emmy this year who joins
us what do you think the Patriots do
with those first-round draft picks such
an interesting deal because it's the
offseason where they let solder leave
right Dion Lewis leaves Malcom Butler
leaves they trade cooks so the cupboards
kind of bare Amendola got and you're
gonna tell Tom Brady hey you threw for
about eight hundred yards in the Super
Bowl and we lost and we're getting rid
of five of your weapons and maybe your
best defensive back but we're gonna
draft a quarterback in the first round
and there's talk that with the 23rd and
31 they package that and even move up
further to get one of these guys that is
truly putting a line in the sand saying
this ain't about you Tom this is about
the future and this is a team before you
and if I'm Tom Brady that's a tough pill
to swallow
it's almost I'm more concerned about his
reaction to if they do take a
quarterback in the first round which
they very well
might do then who the quarterback is and
how it fits in with Belichick like it
could be Mason Rudolph Lamar Jackson
Luke [ __ ] whoever what's Brady's
reaction that next morning when we don't
get our an offensive tackle we didn't
take a pass rusher you took my backup I
don't know
give me the team that shakes up the
draft buffaloed him the most intriguing
team because everyone else jumped out of
the gates to get these free agent
quarterbacks whether it be Denver saying
we're getting with Keenum cousins
Bradford all these guys even the Jets
were like almost panic mode Bridgewater
and McCown give us something they sat
back said who's left
agent McCarran all right affordable deal
eight million trade Courtney Glen the
Buffalo Bills now have the 12 to 20
second not high enough to get one of the
top four guys this is not they're not
gonna be there so that means they have
to make some moves and the connections
are interesting because Dave gentlemen
the GM of the Giants was Brandon beans
boss the GM of the Buffalo Bills when
they were in Carolina together they know
each other very well that's not a
difficult phone call to make it's what
does it cost to get from 12 to 2
you think buffing because I think
Buffalo is still the wild card here that
Buffalo could shake it up to move up
because they're nervous I think they
want Josh Allen but you know Sam Donald
it's not a bad consolation but no and
that's named Arnold in for a meeting I
think today sand Arnold's with them
Baker may feel could be very intriguing
big I hate to hype up Baker may feel
more than he needs to be hyped you think
hyped everywhere he's got a docu-series
about him on right now which is always
needed um
Baker's beloved by these teams he comes
in he had dinner with multiple teams and
I'm getting texts from teams meeting I
get this kid real I'm like I don't know
I'm like everyone says he's amazing like
he's amazing on the board he's amazing
in the room yeah but man Johnny Manziel
fooled everybody
I felt like an act right EJ Manuel is
love everybody loved him yes the Baker
Mayfield love is real though and if he
goes third overall to the Jets I would
not be surprised yeah see that I love
this but I hate this because there's so
much misinformation out there and then
you feel like sometimes you're trying to
clean up the messes and you know
somebody spilled something in aisle six
and then you got to go in and say no
that's not what I'm hearing that's not
true so there's so much misinformation
here yeah and let me explain to people
like when you see some of these reports
from the anonymous Scouts like
the stuff is out there like a lot of
times that stuff is real it's just who
has the power in the building like it's
one thing if you're college you know
personnel guy says yeah we don't like
Josh Rosen don't don't report it from me
but you know it's true but if the GM
loves them and he's gonna be the one
with the ultimate decision it might not
mean anything so it's the power
structures of each building and what
each building wants and what they need a
lot of these teams the Patriots for
example Bill Belichick never has to
worry if he makes messes up this 23rd
and 31st he's good right but if you are
the Jets if you are you know some of
these teams are top 10 if you're the
coli you gotta kind of make the right
pick and there's a lot of pressure and
that's why sometimes the safer pick is
made then the team that really wants to
go for the home run okay
the guy that we're talking about five
years from now regardless of position is
who great question I'm gonna go out on a
limb and it's not fun but as an NBC
network you guys can appreciate the
notre dame love Quintin Nelson is being
discussed as a hall-of-famer not a Pro
Bowl or not at all Pro but he's an
offensive guard and I literally fell
asleep saying his name so if you're an
offensive guard you're not getting the
same height but they say he is the most
surefire offensive line prospects in
sack Martin came out a couple years ago
with the Cowboys everyone's like that's
gonna be a stud in the league so if
that's the case and you know you're
getting a Hall of Famer but doesn't
touch the football ever he's blocking
for your quarterback and running back
like where do you value that what is the
value of a Hall of Fame offensive guard
yeah but Peter I have to start valuing
these linemen because we value the edge
rusher somebody has to block these guys
in interior offensive linemen well I
know but as big as he is why can't I
make him a tackle sure but but I've
heard you know I told these guys when I
came head one day after talking to this
scout and he said you know the guy who
will be up on the boards and you know
nobody's there gonna discount him
because he's an offensive lineman his
Clinton Nelson yeah they said he is as
he's one of those guys that you see once
every 10 years that he's gonna go in and
he's gonna be a great great player if
they tell you hey you're gonna get Steve
Hutchinson yes you're gonna get him you
would sign up for that wouldn't you
would you had to overall you know what's
the value choice of guard if you're the
Giants yeah you can if I give you a Hall
of Fame you're signing right here they
say Hall of Fame guard the next 15cms he
will play there
if I give you ten seasons where your
all-pro would you sign up for that
number two overall I think you have to
rarely take the best player right it's
always quarterbacks say Quan Barclay
where does he rank best player in the
dirt everyone says number two behind
Nelson are number one okay you know
where's he go but you can't tell me that
a male running backs don't matter
because they do if you're a really good
for nethelp Jackson so he can really
help the race yes here's the other thing
the quarterback who I'm yelling on the
hood I like this the quarterback value
is interesting and I hate to get into
the economics of it but Kirk Cousins
just sign for 30 million dollars right
Marcus Mariota
and his four seasons gonna make six
million a year so in the new CBA since
2011 if you draft the quarterback in a
first-round get him for five years at a
bargain-basement price so there's a
value to do that to take an offensive
guard when you can get a quarterback for
you know five cents on the dollar I
don't know it does come down to you get
five-year windows in the NFL that's
really what did it all right it's done
that's it and when you get that
five-year window if you get that
quarterback out of bargain who comes in
in place for you then you can spread the
money around and if you strike gold then
you have an opportunity to play for the
Superbowl which is why I can't hate I
wanna LA is doing they see the window at
Jerrod golf in two years they have to
renegotiate and give him probably twenty
five million dollars at the bare minimum
he does everything right we can't fit
for it this is the window not five years
when he's at his best this is the window
in year three because we're paying him
nothing does it worry you that you're
bringing in a lot of personalities there
with the Rams a little bit mcveigh's
confident that he can handle this and
you know the coach and from the owner on
down he'll say I will sacrifice
personality and potentially chemistry
issues for having the best towel on the
field we'll make it work it's always
great to see you I love coming in he's a
Peter Schreyer NFL Network's good
morning football they did not get
nominated for a Sports Emmy oh but they
did last year and lost now you said that
you got nominated last year because of
you yes okay I've been featured enough
you can see him on a good morning
football Monday through Friday at 7:00
a.m. Eastern he tries to get some air
time and
Network providing live coverage of the
draft from Dallas Fox will simulcast NFL
network's coverage rounds one two and
three Peter Schreyer Thank You Pete
thank you for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]